Annelise okay analise is fine listen
Annalise is working it out like we all
are working it out and it looked like he
was gonna go for another bullet we're
gonna be learning a lot about why she
calls him Christophe and where that
comes from him he was gonna pretty much
shoot her right there and the reason why
he doesn't is because she says a name
that is his name or was his name we
don't really know if you're finally
getting it get to see why it is that she
feels that responsibility towards him
responsibility and protection but I
think that that may be in in question
after what he did I'll be done in just a
little bit it's gonna be a little
jumping around we're gonna be learning a
little bit more about our backstories
and getting a little more a few more
clues about who we are and learning a
lot more about Annalise Sam's previous
relationship when he was still alive
I think that as soon as you feel like
you're writing these characters off that
there couldn't be anybody more
despicable is when you just open your
heart to them once again bye episode 10
a lot of questions will be answered I
hope that you'll be able to see the
reason why she picked us all we find out
Frank's reason this coming episodes he
sleep at night sometimes you have to
wonder I I wonder about him sometimes do
but the sad truth is he sleeps alright
he's a complicated guy we're all
starting to have a few secrets from each
other Frank ever be found out maybe
maybe maybe a lot of maybes on our show
also you're gonna see her relationship
with Frank go to the next level
well I already saw that she met the
family she did she met the family which
is crazy I don't think I'd ever and sure
I don't think Laurel would ever
introduce her family but you'll see why
I am saying